so would you say that was your defining
moment when you actually
became a professional because i'm you
know the stephen pressfield model of
that resistance from the war of art
where they say that uh he i don't know
if you've read the book it's fantastic i
have not okay i have it it's one of
those things on the shelf say i've got
to read this but it's important
well he talks about the resistance
whether it's from people around you
whether it's from yourself
and
once that artist breaks through that
being so fearful to show that film or
whatever it is that's stopping them
those excuses that's kind of the moment
when they turn pro so to speak
so do you think that was the moment when
you finally said you know what i've had
enough trying to almost get this job
i've come close
for some reason i haven't made it
i've always been cut out but this this
time i'm doing it i'm gonna have that
thing to put in front of people
and that was the moment that you turned
professional
that you turned that was certainly a
breakthrough
deciding to raise money and
make an independent film was certainly a
breakthrough moment for me
i hesitate to say that's when i became a
professional
because it was nearly 10 years before
that i'd been hired
to uh to direct a film
and so i would argue that you're a
professional as soon as somebody pays
you to do what you do
but coming to the conclusion that nobody
was going to do it for me
and i had to make this happen myself
was certainly a
the key moment
in getting to where i am today and mind
you where i am today is no great shakes
i mean
maybe
sharknado 2 will come out and people
will realize that the first one wasn't a
fluke and that we actually know what
we're talking about
and then myself and
anthony the director and some other
people involved will uh will be taken
even more seriously
but
that that was the key moment that led to
where i am now and hopefully will lead
to even more
you